toutes une vue sur les réseaux été
cliquée voilà côté tout le monde parler
de toi je m'y attendais en fait ouais y
avait déjà eu une première vague en fait
suite à ma venue au meeting de nantes a
tout de suite vu en fait vous voyez dans
les truites cité tout de suite les
réactions des gens est aussitôt j'ai vu
que ça
les tweets c'était beaucoup de tes infos
negro ou alors tu fais honte à ta
communauté nique ta race même on va te
décapité si je venais ici et donc j'ai
décidé de porter plainte donc je le
porterai plainte voilà ça commence à
faire beaucoup quand même et j'ai eu
peur même de venir quand même parce
qu'on m'a dit que je venais ici on
décapiterait il s'initie à tpm ça m'a
dit si tu viens à paris où elle là parce
que c'est le mot qui va avec on va
décapité donc voilà mais je suis venu
quand même et je vais déposer plainte
c'est incroyable donc tu es venu quand
même oui ça c'est quand même merci
d'être là merci d'avoir un panneau mais
c'est moi qui te remercie est-ce que tu
étais parce que tout le monde à paraître
toi parce que tout le monde s'est posé
la question est-ce que tu étais à cette
place et le début d'ailleurs c'est moi
parce qu'on a laissé moins de monde mais
je te dis moi je dis les choses tu vois
tanguy tanguy tout le monde dit ouais à
mon avis ils ont voulu le mettre là
voilà il sait ce que j'ai lu sur les
réseaux c'est le genre c'est un alibi
pour eric d ça c'est insupportable
mais tu étais att l'appui les buts
étaient générés depuis le début c'est
moi que voulu mettre là d'accord j'ai
insisté même personne c'est dire à
quelqu'un de l'organisation venons du
tout ce mois ci sans doute à mettre
comme ça moi tu met fin aux rumeurs
aulas qui a eu lieu sur le réseau c'est
moi qui ai insisté j'ai toujours voulu
me mettre ici derrière eric zemmour
d'accord non seulement parce que moi je
voulais être le plus preuve le plus près
possible d'eric zemmour pendant le
meeting mais voilà tout souffert du
meeting rt tête il a réussi son
lancement tout à fait incroyable c'était
vraiment enivrant tous ces drapeaux
français cette ferveur j'étais vraiment
content d'être là ça t'a pas gêner
d'apparaître sur toutes les télévisions
n'a pas eu peur non non vraiment non je
n'assume complètement complètement j'ai
aucun problème avec ça ça m'a coûté des
amitiés j'ai perdu des amis vraiment ah
ouais ça raconte-nous était potes quand
ça s'est passé c'est à 18 ans non mais
ça fait quand même déjà étudiant en
licence de droit à 18 ans
18 ans j'étais 3e 2
donc déjà tu m'as mis six classes dans
la tête c'est un truc de foot en 3e
année donc il s'en servir à nous en
première ligne mais la neige tombée en
troisième c'est pour moi entraîner c'est
pour moi donc être ça c'est cadeau ça tu
pars avec non mais c'est fou et enjoy
tombe à quettehou ouais ouais mais ça
fait un mois que moi j'ai fait un bac
pro mois d'un combat professionnel tu as
bien fait ce que tu veux
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce tu
as dit à tes potes tu leur as dit ni
sayej que je moi j'ai toujours été fier
en fait de leur dire quand on parlait de
politique de leur présenter mon
engagement voilà de leur dire que je
soutenir exe moore a très clairement
j'ai jamais eu peur de le dire à
personne pourquoi tu me soutiens eric
zemmour je vous dirais que j'aime parce
que je suis en accord avec ses idées et
avec le constat qu'il dresse concernant
la situation de la france depuis
plusieurs années sur quoi sur le sens la
semelle sur les maigres
le bilan qu'il a dressée jusqu'à hier
parce que hier il a commencé à
développer d'autres choses quand il
industrie etc jusqu'à hier il développé
seulement ces idéologies sur sur
l'immigration ça c'est ça qui me
plaisait tout à fait ça me convient
c'est que sur la sécurité en france
pourquoi ça j'entends beaucoup ça chez
les jeunes oui de table 18 ans mais la
sécurité revient souvent pourquoi qu'est
ce qui se passe mais parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus laisser
je pense tranquillement tout cas pour un
citoyen français lambda que ce soit nos
femmes où nos filles se promener
librement sans qu'elles risquent de se
faire agresser ou ce genre de choses je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le risque est
multiplié challans voilà donc tu disais
que ça avait coûté des amitiés tu leur
as dit quoi tu leur as dit je vais je
vais rejoindre eric zemmour à tes potes
et ouais ouais je leur ai dit alors il
naquit monde y mette en huit rencontres
jouées à l'extrême
l'horreur quasiment le nazisme
c'était vraiment enfin ça les a choqués
pour la plupart en fait il n'a certes
rien 16h au kenya afin qu'ils parlent
plus oui mais je m'en fiche finalement
puisque je pense que j ai gagné
finalement et puis j'ai beaucoup d'amis
qui ont dit bah écoute mon engagement et
le tir il est honorable puisque
finalement
sur soi des menaces mais tu tiens quand
même le coup tu lâches pas tout tu
laisses pas tout tomber et finalement on
papa de nous te lâcher en plus qu voilà
donc tu as un engagement qui est le tien
on n'est peut-être pas d'accord sur
toutes les idées mais c'est pas pour
autant que l'on puisse parler ouais donc
voilà donc pour toi voilà c'est pour moi
c'est un engagement qui vient du coeur
c'est profond et il est hors de question
que j'abandonne et vos enseignants ils
ont ils réagissent alors on a faim ils
réagissent
j'aimerais sûr que dans certains
certains milieux des enseignants s'est
très très mal vue de rejoindre de
rejoindre oui mais à la fin ça arrive à
la fac wii afin qu'ils la fassent à leur
famille l'élève va pas dire ah tiens il
ya c'est pas ton qu'il a un nom mais si
on me filme en courant à la carabine a
qui s'amusent du film n'est pas les
professeurs par les professeurs bien sûr
mais il ya des professeurs qui font des
allusions quand je discute avec certains
profs en a qui me disent j'espère que
ton est mauvais ne mettra pas le régime
de vichy quand même ou alors oui mais
zemmour te rends compte c'est quelqu'un
d' extrémistes et c'est ce qui te plaît
cg zemmour donc tu dis pas ce que c'est
tu comprends qu'il dédia doit avoir des
potes à toi qui doivent être choqués
doivent se dire c'est bizarre tanguy qui
rejoint eric zemmour qui soutient avec
zemmour qui travaille pour avec des mots
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui te séduit mais
comme je les salue parce qu'à 18 ans est
vrai qu on se dit qu'est ce qui s'est
passé avant tu étais avant tu oses tu
avais un engagement politique ou pas du
tout non on ne peut pas dire ça non non
j'ai toujours eu des idées que je
pourrai classé comme étant à droite mais
je n'ai pas eu d'engagement en
particulier spécifique de encore partie
donc là la cia ait pas eu eric zemmour
torrent avait personne athènes un
candidat non non non honnêtement on à
marine le pen non non non janvier pas de
candidat particulier d'accord mais eric
zemmour c'est aussi son courage qui m'a
séduit qui est le sien depuis 30 ans
c'est à dire de faire face à toutes les
critiques
avec le risque qui est le sien
c'est-à-dire d'être menacés de subir des
attaques et ceo d agression et j'ai
toujours été enfin j'ai été séduit par
le courage donc comme je vais le dire
qui est le sien il affronte toutes les
critiques et toutes les insultes qu'on
peut lui préférer je trouve ça vraiment
admirable de sa part mais ce qu'eric
zemmour quelqu'un de télé son équipe et
a contacté aujourd'hui ou
notamment bas j'ai reçu le soutien
stanislas rigaud le président de
génération z je connais bien peut ainsi
que divers qui est également responsable
chez génération z et puis voilà aussi de
tous de l'ensemble des militants
finalement puisque je reçois des
centaines de messages de soutien aussi
tu as peur au sein du groupe non pas du
tout non non j'ai pas peur mais non à la
tranquille dans la rue et qui amène tout
seul et n'a pas demandé donc sous
protection non dans toutes les menaces
que tu as reçu cette touche pas non
honnêtement ça me fait ni chaud ni froid
tes parents ils disent quoi mes parents
sont plutôt inquiets parce que les corps
alors qu'il en faut un peu mais les
parents
aimants mais mes parents ça les inquiète
et ça les a inquiétés parce que
forcément quand on vous dit wallah toi
je vais te tuer on va te retrouver on va
retrouver où tu habites pour essayer
d'attraper etc bon bah c'est pas
rassurant pour personne est juste mais
n'était pas en mai partage cette idée ou
pas du tout c'est ça aussi c est ce qui
est on dit quelque chose oui oui tout à
fait d'accord et qui sont d'accord avec
wii sont d'accord avec eric zemmour
maintenant il écoute beaucoup plus parce
que forcément bon bah moi je parle
beaucoup de zemmour et il se trouve que
mes parents m'ont bas maintenant il
écoute beaucoup plus aussi mais quand
autant des gens dire qu'eric zemmour un
raciste qu'il un discours assez
est-ce que cette native quoi ça
m'évoque je pense sur la compréhension
parce qu'il faut écouter et lire eric
zemmour moi j'ai pas vu dresser tu dis
aux gens qui disent qu'il est raciste
mais je leur dis qu'ils ont tort